my name is Brenton Bostick my talk is
titled parsing the Wolfram language in
this talk I will give an overview of
Wolfram language syntax I will present a
new parser for the Wolfram language and
I will give applications of the new
parser including profiling and code
coverage
all right welcome my name is Brenton
Bostick I'm going to be talking about
parsing the Wolfram language I'm gonna
blast through a lot of stuff right now
and I'm not gonna be taking a lot of
questions until the end all right so
outline is I'm gonna be talking about
Wolfram language syntax and presenting a
new parser for the Wolfram language that
I've been working on for the the last
year and a half or two years or so and
then talk about instrumentation
technology that uses that parser mainly
profiling and coverage analysis
all right so talking about the Wolfram
language syntax about a thousand
different long names two-thirds of which
are letter like some characters and a
third are punctuation things like this
people might be familiar with or not
eighty or so ascii operators like span
double factorial and two-way rule about
300 or so non ASCII operators like all
of these super crazy things sometimes
you see invisible application all right
so just to quiz everyone quickly how
well do you know Wolfram language syntax
as a warm-up how do you tokenize real
numbers if you have only seen this
sequence of characters so far is that
always going to be a real number just
yell out yes or no no it's not because
you could have turned that into a rule
and that now has turned into a rule
expression all right is that always
going to be a rule assuming nothing
about what comes after no it's not
because that could turn into the dot
operator all right what are all of these
these are all very different from each
other some aren't even valid syntax but
I'm not going to go through which ones
are which are these equivalent if you
care if knowing that alternatives the
ordering inside alternatives does not
matter are these the same no they're not
because we're : has different well yeah
and these are not input cells but : has
different precedents I'm going to just
do that so you can actually double and
triple click to be able to see how
things group that groups the whole thing
but that is only what that alternatives
is there so no they're not the same
thing you have to be very careful about
that how does this parse not how you
might intend how does that parse
similarly I don't mean maybe you do but
I don't want to assume but I know at
least for me it's surprising naming a
pattern on both sides of a branch of
alternatives it's completely fine right
no it's not fine because that does not
do what you think it does because that
is what that alternative statement is
and I know people have written that code
because I've written that code before
what does this parse to serious question
what does this parse - well I mean span
is involved yes but yeah however it
depends on what you're asking because if
you actually ask the kernel what it
thinks it will say something else and
this just highlights a problem that the
there's not complete parse or parity
between the kernel and the front-end and
so and also relatedly what does this
parse - if you I mean it fails I don't
know but should it fail because we have
factorial I I don't even know if it I
don't even know anymore anyway quickfire
what is that
I don't know I'm honestly asking yeah
but it's also because well I hold yeah I
mean because it's yeah okay because it's
being set because that's only how that's
grouping but it depends on if you're in
the kernel or and they're the front-end
and okay
so that what does that parsh - what does
that parse - and what does that parse -
which is actually real code that is kind
of scary because that might not be this
whole thing might not be doing what you
think it does because that might not be
what you think it is all right are there
operators that are both prefix and in
fix well I mean I probably wouldn't be
asking if like the answer was no but +
and - people might know about span which
is crazy bang which is crazy plus plus
and minus - are all examples of this
so I mean definitively yes yes symbols
may have non ASCII characters I mean you
know we have alpha as a symbol you know
and everything what are there any non
ASCII symbols that are actually in
system I mean yeah so you know the
formal yeah so super cool
are there any binary operators that are
not in fix think polish notation or
reverse polish notation because the
differential D binds to X and so
integral actually takes two arguments it
well that's already define I mean yeah
okay I could clear that but yeah so
maybe a little bit obscure but that's
the business of what a parser has to
handle so anyway moral of the story is
Wolfram language syntax is complicated
tokenizing is actually harder than
parsing in my opinion but that's I mean
the subjective thing there are lots of
operators in Wolfram language with
unintuitive precedences and colon is its
own beast that I'm not going to be
getting into so why write a new parser
if it seems to be under the old parser
seems to completely understand the
language well there are limitations
because
you can only have a I mean it's around
256 I give or take so I just at 260 but
you'll only have a predefined depth of
expressions that can be parsed down
until you start running into errors and
250 ain't that big and so in the real
world people have actually hit this
limit before you get an error what's the
error because I mean I know I you know
there's no reporting and weird things
like this parsing differently than this
in the kernel yeah so the kernel in the
front end are not completely in parity
which can lead to a lot of
head-scratching and so I think these are
all good motivations for a new parser
where you could have chief parity and
answered read at least address all of
these points in some way so all right
and then just for Halloween I didn't
wanted to throw this in don't evaluate
these in your kernel just just don't
yeah okay so design goals of a new
parser I'm not even going to do it
because I need to still give my
presentation design goals of a new
parser I think I wanted to main claim
clean separation between these different
layers in which I've called the byte
stream the source character stream the
Wolfram language character stream token
stream and expression stream bytes are
at the lowest level and expressions are
at the highest level and this is all
stuff in-between I'm not going to be
talking about what they all completely
are but I can answer questions
afterwards in maintaining clean
separation between levels of abstraction
between concrete syntax aggregates and
tax and abstract syntax and aggregate
syntax is actually a term of art that
I've made up because I felt a need for
this in-between state which I'll talk
about later in and better error handling
reporting and recovery so some little
some different concepts a source
character there are eight source
characters in this selection right now
but there's only one Wolfram language
character there is once one source
character here and one Wolfram language
character there so hopefully that's
enough explanation for people
trivia is what I'm calling comments
whitespace new lines and line
continuations and aggregate syntax is
therefore concrete syntax but with
trivia removed concrete syntax think of
boxes in the front-end and abstract
syntax think of full form in the kernel
roughly I know they're different but
anyway so some implementation details it
is modeled as a Pratt parser which is a
recursive descent parser that associates
semantics with tokens instead of grammar
rules some line of code outputs for
Jason and Harris
he was asking yes there's about eighteen
seventeen whatever thousand line
fourteen whatever lines of C++ code and
you talk about implementing them as
there are various parse let's I didn't
make up that term in the parser that you
address various things you know binary
operators you have group operators you
have in fixed postfix and prefix and
then you have to address little special
cases that maybe this list is a little
bit too long but that's the Wolfram
language for you
colon has special things equal because
of dot sorry equality parcel it's and
vector in equality parcel that speak so
we like to get all of those together in
one unit differently trailing things
that can be just in fixed but are
trailing like commas and semicolons
integral has its own thing semi span has
its own thing and each one of the
ternary operators have to have their own
special parse let's also so yeah so
anyway new parser it's called it's
implemented in the ast Pacolet so you
can just do this and so this is the
output of parse string which is the main
function that you'll use you'll see
there's a call node a leaf node which is
the head and leaf node which are the two
arguments to the plus that I gave so you
might wonder maybe not wonder what the
output of the same thing would be and
look it's the same thing with different
source though because you know we space
them out differently the source is
specifying what line and column the leaf
started on and what line and column the
leaf ended on and it's inclusive not
inclusive and exclusive four string
takes benefit even though it's annoying
because now you can't specify zero
length two characters zero length leaves
but whatever and so everything's all on
one line here and so maybe it's a bit
redundant but it gets pretty useful when
you're dealing with files
so yeah parsing strings like I was just
showing if you want to keep track of
concrete syntax you would use concrete
parse string where you now have comments
embedded in wherever you had comments
and it's all very nice but you might not
just be dealing with strings you might
want to also be dealing with files and
so I have an example of the Collatz
problem this has other code in it that
I'll be demonstrating later but it's a
common thing it's just an implementation
of the Collatz function and so you can
parse this file and get a big chunk of
stuff back I assume it's correct I'm
going to keep scrolling and concrete
parse gives even more structure back
yeah like whitespace yeah a lot of
scrolling okay um so one benefit that
you immediately start seeing is that
there's no longer the same stack depth
of limit as before and just to verify
I'm not like there's not something
missing in the alighted stuff this
creates a fully nice full form
expression you can actually go even
higher which is this gonna take I
shouldn't have done that why did that
not even return oh man yeah ha yeah oh
well yeah I shouldn't have done that
alright okay I think we're good to go so
and then a little bit of cheating here
for good formatting I'm going to show
that we have good error reporting with
the linter doing the actual formatting
but the parser is actually doing the
heavy lifting we can actually see that
we get salient error messages depending
on what the error is and the second
example actually illustrating that we
have good recovery after there's a
parsing error it continues and tells you
that there you know you're still
multiplying something by three even
though it's complete gibberish at that
but you might want to go back and
actually fix the problem instead of just
dead stopping right there where the
weird plus was so some applications of
the new parser I'm going to show involve
instrumentation of source code which
means rewriting source code here usually
around the entering and exiting of
functions to do various you know ledger
keeping track tidying type things mainly
profiling and coverage of reporting are
the two main applications I'm gonna be
showing but like Tom said was touching
on in his talk you could also start
applying code transformations like
recognizing that append to inside of a
list may not be that good of an idea and
transforming that automatically in some
way to something more general that would
be more performant so profiling Wolfram
language code I had to quit then anyway
so it's just as well so I'm gonna be
using the same Colette's example that
people may have noticed I artificially
put a pause of 0.1 seconds and but take
us oh I think it's already done
yep so this is a it just returns a list
of the iterates of the Col at starting
27 goes down to one you get a bunch of
data verifying that the data that comes
out has stuff in it we we process it and
then we end up getting a report and I
will blow that up for people's benefit
that might well yeah so you can see that
ninety-nine point five six percent of
the time is spent in the function in the
dot M file at line twenty nine and if we
look at line twenty nine this is this
definition hey and look there's a call
to dummy function which is calling pause
of 0.01 like however many times it was
and that's probably what all the time
was and in fact it was so we can
actually get data-driven we can use data
to help augment our intuition about why
code might be slow because a lot of
times your intuition might be wrong
about what code is slow and it's much
better to actually get something numbers
to tell you
where to look and what the problem is
I'm not taking any question I'm sorry
what that's a good question because it's
actually kind of tricky because I put it
inside of a condition this condition
fires before you've actually entered the
function the dummy function and so
there's like this whole explanatory
comment up here in code you could add a
wrapper of Kult you could actually get
that analysis yeah you know if you knew
if you instrumented every call site of
that function it could then tell you the
time difference between I've started to
enter enter this function and now I'm
actually inside of this function and
it's like there's a lot of stuff that
goes on that takes up a lot of time if
you're not paying attention so yeah good
good good question oh that's the report
yeah okay yeah and so then also coverage
reporting of Wolfram language code that
people would hopefully find useful going
to be instrumenting the same the same
code just verifying a lot of stuff
that's yeah different formatting all
right however this is now using external
commands to actually generate the HTML
and stuff but here I'm not gonna go out
to the show but you know you it's
reporting 80% coverage and some
screenshots but I actually still have
the report so yep and so using L k'v and
Gen HTML you can go here and see I think
I can sum like this lines execute at 70
times this is only executed once 123
times this line is executed zero times
because I define immediately after it
another definition for integer that it
takes that is actually the thing that
gets hit so that's coverage reporting in
the Wolfram language
thanks to the new parser technology okay
so the future
immediately Media goals for the future
is a four matter for Wolfram language
code pretty printer type things that
people might have even been asking about
in the morning you know this morning
we're actively working on a new
formatter if you have any ideas for how
you'd like your code formatted let me
know and then just other idea source map
there's a pack the new package format
supporting that would be very nice
rewriting the whole thing as an LL 1
parser because it's actually well yeah
yeah it crashed so I thought I could
yeah you should still able to hit stack
depth limits but just not as you know
the same before and actually using the
new kernel to return expressions
directly to the kernel and then after
all that actually integrating back into
the kernel and having all of this stuff
for free so thank you come to my talk
finding bugs in the Wolfram language at
4:30 and that's it cool thank you
[Applause]